a funny thing's happened in the last two
and a half weeks
the sun feels like it's shining brighter
the air tastes crisper
and people are breathing a little easier
well that's
thanks to the end of most of the mask
mandates but we'll get to that in a
minute
so what's changed in the last 17 days or
so that has had such a profound impact
on our country
oh that's right we launched jesse waters
prime time
coincidence i think not
come on you know you want to admit it
your life has been better in the age of
prime time
the weather's getting warmer you're
welcome
the dow jones is up over a thousand
points you can thank me later
and we retired tom brady now everybody
else's team has a shot
since our show has kicked off we've had
a pretty good run
and thanks to you
ratings have been really strong over
3 million viewers are watching every
night
vanna white still beating us but
she had a head start
prime time is the number three show in
cable news only tucker and the five are
ahead
so i'm losing to myself
which i'm okay with
i think
for now
we aren't going to sit by as pelosi's
family trades stocks and gets rich
amassing over 300 million dollars in
assets while serving in congress isn't
serving it's swindling
we're blowing this up and congress has
started to listen
looks like liz warren watches prime time
this is the senate's first
bipartisan bill on
ending
stock ownership and trading among
members of congress
the american people have a right to know
that when lawmakers are making decisions
it's about the best interests of the
american people not about the lawmakers
own personal
financial
interests
this bill
is sharp and clean it says
no ownership
no trading
for members or their spouses
it took us less than three weeks to get
pocahontas on our side maybe the squad's
next
and speaking of the squad have you
noticed twitter is a little less
annoying lately
yep that one's on us too
we crossed into aoc's congressional
district to see what her constituents
really thought of her
let's just say we didn't find a lot of
fans
now aocs ditch twitter
saving us all for more videos like this
if
waking up in the morning and doing your
makeup gives you life
then that is amazing and you should do
it
and she isn't the only new yorker whose
sensibilities we've awoken
we called out the big apples surging
crime and retail theft and now even al
sharpton is following our lead
you go to a local pharmacy drain read or
write any of them and you've got to get
someone to help assist you i mean they
have the little button there yep you hit
the buzzer and the guy comes over and
unlocks your toothpaste i mean we cannot
have a culture where people are just at
random just robbing and stealing and is
out of control
we can't have an america where we have
to unlock our toothpaste at duane read
and that's only the beginning guys on
friday we brought you the story of a
brave group of high school students who
stood up to the mask bullies
and we're all walking into the school
with no mask on
you can get me in trouble they can
suspend me i don't care we're done with
this
and obviously all of you are too we want
this to be a peaceful respectful
movement we are just trying to gain back
our rights as citizens if a staff member
asks you to put a mask on you say no
thank you and keep walking and if they
kick you out then go home
and by monday morning their message
moved across the country about as fast
as democrats play the race card
coincidence
i think not
we just want these students to have
their lives back
like these kids in israel when they
learn the mask mandate was over watch
[Applause]
that's the raw emotion and pure joy of
knowing your life
is going back to normal they can finally
see their friends faces and their smiles
that's all we're asking for here in
america
and like i said earlier we're winning
democrat run states pennsylvania
delaware new jersey massachusetts oregon
rhode island and even connecticut have
all gotten smart and are ending their
school mask mandates
or they got some bad polling numbers
but we have a problem
democrats actually want credit for
crushing the virus and lifting mandates
you don't believe me i know it's
preposterous but here's congressman
hakeem jeffries thanking joe biden
under president biden's leadership
a public health infrastructure was put
into place to ensure
that we can do everything possible to
crush the virus
and that is what has been happening
so democrats commit crimes against
humanity and now they want credit for
stopping the crimes
well how nice of them
they're not going to get away with it
biden's average approval has officially
fallen into the 30s
which as a democrat with the full
support of the media is very hard to do
you're welcome for that one too america
so in less than three weeks look at all
the things that we've been able to
accomplish
and we're only getting started we have a
lot more work to do so keep pounding
your congress members and
just to tell them to do something about
the border first of all
refuse to say quiet when your school
board looks to push crt on you and your
kids
and don't listen when the left-wing
media says you're wrong
we all know they really have no clue
what's going on
we live in the era of prime time now
ride with prime time and keep texting
and emailing and speaking out because
we're listening
and this is only the beginning hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else